the first that when i be in the
israel probably under five six years ago
because the one japanese company tried
to listing on a terrible stock exchange
and from the my profession team point we
supported
the one and after that so i've been
there the more than 10 times
i i really joined on the you know
israeli culture
and then the many people to be frank
asking to bringing money from japan and
connecting the business with
japan welcome to 20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
we are in tokyo meet takeshi shinoda
chairman and ceo of arista gora group
takeshi is based in japan in singapore
ceo of arista girl group including
asset management private equity venture
capital and wealth management firms
he has more than 30 years of rich
background in the fields of investment
banking and private banking
meet takeshi takeshi shinoda all the way
from japan
how are you today welcome to my show
okay pretty pretty nice uh today the
japan
weather is very good takeshi can you do
me a favor and just
show us what you're seeing be in front
of you because the view is spectacular
just turn your
turn your computer really quick just so
that we can see it because
it's really beautiful yeah
so wow this is uh the view from my
office
you can see on the tokyo tower
yes
this floor yeah this floor is a 39th
floor
that's why the tokyo tower looks a bit
lower
amazing amazing wonderful well
thank you thank you for joining me from
japan and
and takeshi i'm looking forward to to
talking with you about
your your your personal and professional
life i'm looking forward to talking with
you about your time as the ceo of our
aristogra group
and we're talking about asset management
and private equity but also venture
capital
and you have more than 30 years of
experience in
in investment banking and private
banking and
and i'm looking forward to just hearing
a little bit about your journey and
insight so
perhaps you can start by by sharing with
me a little bit about yourself and
and how you found yourself going into
wealth management
okay um the interesting things is uh
the i didn't plan my journey at all
when i was young to be frank i
just do by my best
each time and the summer
is you know uh taking up or the changing
of my journey
so it's kind of a no trend journey
but uh that is uh sometimes bringing in
a good way
so to be frank the i started
my career from the manufacturer so not
uh not
financial industry to be found i spent
four
years over there uh very very hard work
like on the uh every day that i walked
by 2 a.m or 3 a.m on the market
for my justice yeah short shorts
short sleep and then back into the you
know office that that was
my my to be frank my 20s
wow and then
uh that time is late 80s so
the japan the financial market is the
so-called
bubble and after that of course bubble
fast but the
my my neighbors in the uh manufacturer
was
my my colleague in the financial
industry and
they approached me and
hire me in the investment bank at the
time the name is nico securities
and the immediately after my position
was in new york
so i moved to new york from tokyo when i
was starting
wow and so you're you're coming to new
york and you're 30.
why by the way so tell me a little bit
about this decision to move to new york
what triggered it
why why new york from japan
okay when i was a
student in university i came to
us the first time you know for me
for the vlog and i stayed one month over
there and
that's what really impressed her
experience
and after that always you know i'm
looking for the opportunity to working
on uh
outside japan to be frank ideally of
course new york because
the wall street is on the best position
for the banker
yeah of course
and so you come to new york and what do
you do there
the first starting from the fx trader
and the spot trading
and after that i change to the equity
market
the trader especially the derivative
trader
so i i enjoyed it
on the other hand of course it's a it's
tough time for me because
i couldn't speak english at all
and so tell me a little bit about not
speaking english at all
and you're coming to new york things are
very hectic in wall street i'm sure
things are moving fast
a lot of uh you know business to be done
and you're coming in and you only speak
japanese you don't speak english
how does that work okay uh
of course you know when i travel in
the u.s or europe
it's okay because uh i'm not a guest
so the people is very kind to me but
when i
live in new york and uh need to do the
business
the other side is the customer or the
client
and i need to the service provider the
requirement of the english level is
completely different
right and so do you how do you
how do you deal with that of course i
why i went to the school the first year
of course
but also the luckily the opportunity
most of my my staff is the american
so anyway i have to speak
in english you had to practice anyways
yeah
it had to happen and
say after three years i
believed i communicated a bit better
than the people
and so do when you move to when you move
to new york
is that do you see that as a sort of
you know temporary relocation do you see
that as
moving countries how do how do you
perceive that moving
okay in in the japanese company
we are having a so-called rotation for
for taking the several physicians and
usually the most of
one position is three years so of course
when i moved to new york yeah the
company is saying and
you're gonna stand three years in new
york and back into tokyo
i see okay okay okay so now so now
tell me a little bit about this company
and what you're doing there and and
what i'm especially excited to hear
about is also from your perspective what
does it mean
really wealth management in the sense
that a risk
that you're doing with your company um
aristo gora what does it actually mean
you know the combining asset management
wealth management private equity
okay um the waste management
to be frank is quite similar to
so-called
family office service uh of course
we are the assignment agenda we are
investing uh
the family to asset on behalf and try to
getting enough
of course depends on the family but the
stable return or you know higher
high rate down depends on the client
but on the other hand the family
having a lot of not really a problem
with the issue
but always they are having some some
matter like on that you know
or the kids education
or you know like that and not only on
the investment
sometimes we are getting on the the
question or inquiry or you know
the uh on those matters
ideally we need to respond to the
family what is the better order
sometimes of course we are introducing
more the professional like a lawyer
or the tax professional
and so it's the kind of a hub you know
to to connecting an all professional
management service yeah and so within
wealth management though you also have
different verticals right and you have
different types of management from
private equity
to assets to venture capital and and it
sounds to me like
like you're dealing with quite a few of
them at the same time right
yeah um okay uh of course the investment
banking is usually that the definition
of the businesses
we are the servicing to the corporate
from the financial point of view like
monday the financing
sometimes the listing ipo
but of course in general we need to
understand
the business what they are doing and
then trying to do the best service from
the financial
service point of view uh and
sometimes the waste family is running on
the
corporate or the business so right it's
linked to each other and
how do you balance the risk associated
with
these different asset types because you
have different risk involved
in depending on the type of investment
that you're making
if the family asking to to
maintain the asset by us meaning with
the investing by myself
of course the usually they don't take
much risk because this is a family asset
and the family is usually taking the
high risk in their business side
that's why for the financial product
point of view
we are investing in a quite low risk uh
the middle return
and then the point is on the portfolio
management
okay so so takeshi paint me a picture
please of how your day looks how does
the day
of a wealth management person looks from
the moment
you you get to the office or wake up you
choose to the moment that you finish
what is it what does it actually entail
ah it's quite different by each days to
be frank
sometimes of course i wait but
definitely the first i wake up
usually you know five am in the morning
and
yes yes wow
and the checking on you know the email
the overnights uh
the checking on the news for the market
and those things
and then usually i come to the office
around
7 7 30 okay and the
starting in the morning meeting with
myself
a morning meeting with yourself what
does that mean
the okay wanting meetings usually we we
just
gather the whole information what's
going on in the world you know
or the overnight or the day and then
right sometimes of course it's just a
news sometimes it's a long trend
uh of course we talked on isla
and the palestinian issue the
the recently yes of course of course
and so then that's rather the day
what does that actually look like what
what is what is the day-to-day job
uh day-to-day job is uh sometimes of
course uh
the marketing is still always important
for the company so i'm spending my time
for the marketing
on the other hand of course sometimes
unfortunately the issue is happened i
need to spend on
troubleshooting so
yeah it depends
right and so it's like i should tell me
a little bit about you
you know i'm really curious you know
especially when it comes to wealth
management
what do you get excited by so which
which part of this
experience is exciting for you
the the most exciting point
uh for me because from my expense point
i know so many worse people or the worst
family the life not only on the
investment
because when uh yeah
we as having them of course we need to
understand
everything for the family
now is that so when you say the five of
the different characteristics
yes yes how do you know
well okay the first of course we are
checking on how much money they wanna
you know
asking to ask to invest in or the
maintained asset and the starting about
the
last point uh from of course recently
the conference point we need to check
on where the money comes from and
how do they earn the money or you know
the building of an
asset and that is kind of their history
right right and then how does their
when you say we have to understand their
life how what does that mean in terms of
how how that impact your decision
was once they provide them
okay and then of course depending on the
ones that we understand the the family
characteristic
business those risk appetite then
of course we propose that our the
type of service what kind of risk we are
taking and what's kind of
the return that we're going to expecting
which type of
you know asset we're going to invest in
including on the private equity the
venture capital just you know
high liquidity financial product
right right and so transitioning to more
about
the venture capital side aristo gora vc
you've invested in in a few companies
that that i love
i believe nimble is is one of them
and sorry data ai tell me
what is that process like doing it from
japan
investing in the israeli ecosystem okay
uh the first the when i
be in the israel probably under five or
six years ago
because the one japanese company tried
to listing on a terrible stock exchange
and from my professional team point we
supported
the one and after that so i've been
there the more than 10 times
i i really joined on the you know it's
very culture
and then the many people to be frank
asking to bringing money from japan and
connecting the business with japan
that's why
i'm sure i'm building upon the business
no no i'm sure and obviously you know it
sounds
it sounds like a great partnership and
do you feel that the
israeli startups understand
you and they understand what you're
doing from japan
okay the technology-wise
the perfect matchmaking in japan the
israel because
the israeli people is quite uh
quite a from zero to one
and that is quite bad for japanese
people japanese people is very good from
the one to ten but
not zero to one so
technology wise i believe it's it's
really good matching but on your head on
the other hand of course the culture is
completely opposite
uh a scientific is so flexible
and don't hesitate to the fair you know
so that's this yeah and of course
for the small things the japanese people
is
very very punctual the israeli people is
no match
right of course the path to bad traffic
is one reason but
i believe that is not only one
of course now if you had to you know
look in like two three years or five
years into the future
what is where is the aristo girl vc
going and where is the
you know your interaction with the
israeli ecosystem going
okay of course uh
our trunk right now point of view uh
we are trying to increasing the uh the
first of course the communication
uh uh and also the cash or the
technology between the japan israel
meaning is a much much more israeli
company especially on a startup company
gonna be working with japanese japanese
industry especially
the financial industry fine but also the
manufacturer
and then that is expanding to
the world from the business point of
view
that i i really hoping so on the helping
to that direction amazing
very very cool yeah and the
i hope the yeah especially young
japanese people
should be in israel
okay understand the different culture
uh and they then
that's this definitely goes through the
world because
there's so many japanese young people
staying in japan
right now and that is uh one
domestic people than the before
what do you think of the israeli culture
it's a little different
from a lot of other places was it easy
for you to immediately understand it
uh of course that now i'm quite easy to
understand because uh
i have had a good day asian day so
but when i was young for example
whenever the 20s or 30s
probably a bit more difficult to
understand because it's so different
right no no no definitely
and so if you had to speak to
you know young japanese entrepreneurs
investors etc
what advice would you give them in in
that
you know as they are maybe exposing
themselves to israeli culture and vice
versa so i'm gonna ask the same thing
what your advice to israelis in a second
but but to the japanese
what would you say what advice would you
give them about
you know building the relationship in
the israel ecosystem
okay the specific to the japanese young
people
uh the my message is very clear the
don't hesitate to
taking risk when they do change
that is a message i love it and
the same question goes now for the
israeli entrepreneurs so
myself my friends what what advice would
you give
us in relations to the japanese market
or working with
with young japanese people okay because
anyway the
israeli young people already taking a
lot of risk and
challenging yeah so so the advice is
different a little bit of positive
just just for the history
people enjoy
to work with different culture people
and that is that should be quite fun
for them as well i i completely
completely agree
takeshi i really want to thank you for
joining me i
i loved hearing about your journey and i
loved
hearing about you know your insights
into into your industry and the
relationship with israel etc
i have a few questions not about
investment banking but about
you and we'll start off with your
favorite subject
from middle school or high school
my favorite was uh mathematics
mathematics and was there any specific
class in mathematics that particularly
you know geometry algebra calculus
no they generate all mathematics
that's really good and enjoyable for me
amazing i i don't know why but
i always enjoy the mathematics
very very cool and who would be a role
model of yours
or somebody in this world that inspires
you
um it's quite difficult question because
the first of course first
almost 25 the close to the 30 years
i worked for the financial industry i
still finance industry but
within the big investment bank the
global investment bank
so that point i was just a bunker
and on this point my
my kind of uh
the tour of the model is
the name is so-called terra savasana
he is very senior position of the
normula security
and worked for new york when
he was young and actually he wrote
the book and i read it that's why i
love him and also i love the
life a lot by him so that
is one but after that of course i'm
building upon
my business by myself and that is
different
from the one of a banker in the big
organization
so on this point of course the
the right now i don't have any the role
of model
if anyone uh it's good
i really would uh find it because
when i started on my business that is uh
uh when i was a 50s so
wow young i thought to be from
but still i don't know you know 50s to
50s today
is the 20s of the past very young
yeah but the point is that anytime
that people can start new things it's
definitely not
great not to worry so
i love it i love it and takeshi what
would be three words that you would use
to describe yourself
um
probably each people see the different
different with me
but my point of view and
how do i see myself the first of course
i'm very shy
okay yeah
and also i believe the most of japanese
people is very shy
interesting so yeah that's why
if not only the young people but the old
people in israel
they if that they are talking to the
japanese people from their their side
that the always the japanese people is
happy but
it's quite difficult for the most of
japanese people to talk to
the different culture from the japanese
people's side
so that's right because of the simply
it's shy
so of course i i i'm also very shy
yeah uh okay
and yeah the
as i said my favorite is mathematics so
i believe that i'm quite a logical
person
okay logical analytical as well
i guess yes and i i think
that sometimes that is very important
for the visions of course
yeah we need the passion uh just
logical is not enough the passion is
very important but uh
right to be frank i'm very logical plus
so we have shy we have logical and one
will be a third one
uh don't know that
i am but i wanna be
he's some challenging people the
challenger
uh a challenger yeah i'm always trying
to be the challenger
i'm not sure still i'm challenged or not
but
i wanna be there i love it takeshi
thank you so so much for joining me all
the way from japan this was a wonderful
i can't wait to meet in person either in
tel aviv or in tokyo
it will make it happen either either way
yeah and thank you for sharing your time
with me i really enjoyed it
and the best of luck with the business
and continue making
continue making amazing investments
especially in the israel ecosystem
and thank you for everything and stay
safe and stay healthy
thank you thank you very much for
inviting me